exacto el que primero ha reaccionado es
el presidente joe biden quien en un
comunicado agradeció a los demócratas
del senado de la cámara de
representantes por empujar este plan de
ayuda de 1,9 billones de dólares hizo
mención especial y agradecimiento
especial a nancy pelosi presidenta de la
cámara de representantes dijo que es
posiblemente la más capaz de los
presidentes que ha tenido la cámara de
representantes en la historia de eeuu
bailén dijo que firmara esta ley el
viernes desde la casa blanca y anunció
también un tour un tour de dos semanas
por eeuu precisamente para vender la
importancia de este plan de rescate
económico el tour empezará en los
estados de delaware y de pensilvania
mañana por la noche hablará yo bailén a
toda la nación precisamente para
explicar cuál será la próxima etapa en
este plan de rescate contra el
coronavirus y es que además el plan de
rescate se aprobó el nombramiento de
medicare land como el nuevo fiscal
general de eeuu quienes graben y que
significa el número bien
para el departamento de justicia
el senado que es el encargado de aprobar
los candidatos en el gabinete y los
jueces en el país aprobó con 70 votos a
favor 30 en contra a garland card line
había sido juez de la corte distrital
del distrito de columbia una de las
cortes más importantes en eeuu y barack
obama lo nombró terminando su
administración para ser juez de la corte
suprema de justicia de eeuu sin embargo
fueron los republicanos que en ese
entonces tenían mayoría en el senado los
que bloquearon este nombramiento ahora
en garland entonces es confirmado para
estar a cargo de la cartera del
departamento de justicia él lo ha dicho
que hablan del propio grave ha dicho que
su objetivo y su prioridad en su agenda
o hacer pues responsabilizar e
investigar aquellos que se tomaron el
capitolio el 6 de enero y ha repetido ya
varias veces que él él va a ser el
abogado del pueblo y no el abogado de
una persona en referencia a 28